[Musique]
dominant les français découvrent sur
leur écran jennifer jeune chanteuse de
19 ans qui sous leurs yeux se révèle
dans l'émission star académie voilà on
va voir les images et puis après je
verrai commenté c'est ça si depuis
jennifer est devenue une artiste
importante en france
elle ne parle que très rarement de ses
débuts dans l'émission qu'il a pourtant
révélé six arrivées occassionnés astarac
déjà un petit peu à reculons ce que
j'avais hyper peur et je voyais des gens
du jury sortir ghislain bourque et j'y
suis allé et peu importe l'occasion de
l'anniversaire des 20 ans du programme
jennifer a décidé de s'exprimer sur la
star academy et cette période folle qui
lui a permis de devenir la star de
variétés qu'elle est aujourd'hui
à 20 ans je voulais chanter et je
chantais déjà c'est sur instagram que la
chanteuse s'est confiée sur ses
souvenirs
le soir du 20 octobre 2001 je découvrais
le fameux château de dammarie les lys
entre pudeur et insouciance je n'avais
que 18 ans et cette aventure
s'apparenter plus pour moi un départ en
colonie de vacances qu'un rêve de star
mais très vite l'aventuré va prendre une
toute autre ampleur
nous étions tous très très loin de la
réalité c'est bien cette insouciance qui
m'a permis de ne pas imploser
on n'est jamais préparé à une notoriété
si soudaine et incontrôlable des
confidences rare qui rappelle à quel
point cette émission a marqué sa vie
comme celle de toute une génération
[Applaudissements]
jennifer allora d'équité de nouveau
maman je fais un gros bisou a dit non je
n'y tiens si elle nous regarde
bon alors pas jean pascal moi je la
félicite aussi pour nouvelle naissance
qui a eu bien sûr mais heureusement
alors avant qui est bien sûr une
polémique encore puisque chaque fois que
j'ai quelque chose
j'adore jane superbe carrière je suis
depuis toujours moi ce qui m'embête un
peu c'est que pendant 20 ans et c'est
pas la seule il ya quelques personnes
qui ont gagné au ciment à star académie
qui pendant vingt ans il fallait pas
trop leur parler de la star ac
il en parlait pas trop parce que il
voulait plus être associé à cette image
et c'est donc moi ce qu'ils savent c'est
pas que ça m'embête ça m'emmerde parce
qu'il faut pas renier entre guillemets
ce qui nous a amené jacques huard a des
supers vie des super carrière et ça
m'embête un peu que ce soit vingt ans
après la preuve dans l'émission de
samedi n'est pas là il n'y a pas qu'elle
qui manque en a d'autres et qu'ils aient
pas oui elle était enceinte mais au mois
de septembre donc si ça a été plus long
peut-être pour el watan et je pense que
voilà il y en a beaucoup qui n'était pas
là je trouve ça un peu maladroit
vis-à-vis du public des gens qui nous en
est là donc c'est ça qui m'embête un
petit peu après c'est plus c'était le
moyen de tous se retrouver et c'est ce
qui m'embête un petit peu voilà on sait
pas eu donc c'est des artistes petite
déception pas du tout alors par contre
c'était une super amourette je passe un
très bon j'adore faire j'ai pas dit que
je l'aimais par terre on dit pas de
rebond à la télé tout aller kevin jean
pascal franchement tu sais que je
t'adore non j'suis j'entends ce que
j'entends ce que tu veux dire il va bien
fait sauf que il faut pas oublier de
l'autre côté aussi du côté des artistes
aujourd'hui il ya un lobbying et nos
pressions de l'industrie musicale que
surtout en france on met des étiquettes
à des gens et qu'aujourd'hui l'étiquette
télé crochet télé réalité6 pour l'asim
on ne bosse pas plus mais qui bossent
kevin qui est le patron genia un moment
signer ce gène à mâcher désolé tu as
besoin de bouffer on te disant n'arrête
non mais quel moment faut faire baisser
son froc études il ya un moment il faut
être fier de ce qu'on a fait dans une
boîte de musique elle me différent tu
veux vendre des disques tu portes plus
larges et bien non il ya une différence
à la creuse entre rognés et ne pas
vouloir en parler et alimente annonça le
show ventana jamais diamant sur la star
ac mais au leader c'est pareil fait tu
vois les gens n'ont pas parlé oui
pourquoi pas daniel non
j'ai appris quelque chose en regardant
un petit peu on a failli quand même
passé à côté de jennifer parce que cette
émission c'était juste après le loft il
y avait eu l'histoire de la piscine et
il voulait qu'il se passe des choses
dans leur nouvelle émission 1 et ils
avaient sélectionné est presque une
hôtesse de l'air d'une trentaine
d'années à forte poitrine avec une
grosse bouche et passionnelle qui
attendent excusez nous mais on cherche
quand même des chanteurs et ils ont pris
jennifer la rochelle je sais pas si sa
maison de disques ont six est elle
capable y participer à l'émission
mémoires moi je suis comme vous et moi
j'adore jennyfer je la trouve
charismatique elle a eu une carrière
incroyable bien celui-là mener elle a
quand même fait partie du jury de the
voice
moi je peux comprendre qu'elle a eu
envie de se dire mais moi j'y vais pas
moi je suis une vraie star j'ai pas
envie d'y aller
des choses comme sonné dans des états où
cette foi guelmim faut c'est parce
qu'elle a fait mais je crois comprendre
c'est à dire voilà je vais pas mis
d'accord c'est peut-être parce que c'est
la star mais c'est aussi parce que
jennifer elle valait quelque chose parce
que sinon l'ours l'y aider
évidemment parce que c'est vrai mais il
dut est nette mais elle a démarré grâce
à pau à l'euro ni parent star académie
de suite de ta vie parce que tu as été
célèbre grâce à une émission vidéo gag
et l'après vidéo gag pendant 20 ans tu
vas parler des relations d'interviews
nos machines jolie maison grâce aux fils
je trouve ça mal à me voir après je n'ai
rien contre elle je trouve que c'est pas
bien c'est tout je parie que tu as
besoin d'être rassuré t'inquiète pas
mènera va bien au contraire on réagit
pas tous de la même manière c'est à des
chinois
je te jure que ça va me servir des gens
parce que je me dis ou pas même une
armée le premier jean pascal
allongez vous la raconter
ménard mais jennifer c'est l'amour de
filet j'ai super c'est un amour je
l'adorent je suis sa carrière elle le
mérite elle est géniale
on s'est revu sur le plateau tpp grâce à
cyril parce qu'on n'était pas revu
depuis 20 ans c'est donc tu voulais la
voir mais non mais on essaie de te
revoir laventure qu'on a vécu est
extraordinaire c'est juste que ça m'a un
petit peu embêté qu'ils soient pas là
sur le programme parce qu'il fallait y
être et c'est juste vouloir corriger je
n'ai rien contre elle un bon